okay so what is this somebody said okay
so let's see i haven't even know what
this is but american dad intro speedrun
here we go okay here we go
[Music]
okay messed up already
what is this is this for real nope the
exact same thing okay
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
i've never seen this it's actually great
[Music]
okay this is basically what every
speaker
okay i'm happy with that i'm i'm happy
with that that's a good time
hey guys funny man in the suit and tie
back and today i just wanted to make a
quick video discussing my
uh american dad intro speed run of 5.77
seconds
um as you saw there was a lot of failed
attempt and then you saw the successful
attempt at the end this took a lot of
time and practice there's a lot of
things that um
it was very difficult to okay i forgot
that miami milf is like 70 years old
listen a speed run is
basically beating the game as fast as
you can
and and there's like this you know you
want to be the person to beat the game
as fast as they can
and a lot of them use like glitches and
and like um exploits that are built into
the game
that's what a speed run is
so you so now you know
okay i'm not listen now you're being a
dick you know what a glitch is
um yeah miami gilf
uh
they they they use exploits they used to
have anything they can
am i going to play cyberpunk maybe when
it [ __ ] comes out in
2027 um
i mean i guess but isn't evan's half the
fun enjoying the cutscenes and stuff
people put a lot of effort into it oh my
god
you're such a concerned mom people
worked really hard on that game
people worked really hard and you're
just going to ignore the cutscenes now
i don't know it just feels like they
really worked really hard
[Laughter]
people worked really hard to make the
game and you're just gonna skip this
cutscenes
what's wrong with you people
they worked really hard on those
cutscenes and you're just gonna
skip them look this guy beat super mario
3 in four minutes
four minutes that's not fun at all
what about the cutscenes
no one's thinking of the cutscenes
people work really hard on cutscenes
they're sitting there and they're trying
to make their parents proud and you're
just gonna skip them
exactly why did i even get you this game
if you're not gonna look at the
cutscenes that they worked hard on
i drove all the way to gamestop
five minutes they beat mario three five
minutes it took me
[ __ ] five months i was a kid
but still i do like mario speedruns
because some of them require a lot of
hard tricks mario 64 is a really fun
speedrun game i've seen those
i mean trust me you shouldn't just put
speed around the background and just
watch people um
[Music]
just do
[Music]
weird the problem is probably the long
speed run right
so like they you get like 10 minutes
into a game and you'll mess up one jump
and then you have to start again
and it's just over and over and over and
over
and you're missing all the cutscenes the
cutscenes are the best part
of the game i want a story
tyler i did not spend 60 on this game
for you to skip the cutscenes
uh i love you my email if you know that
friday review of the wizard
oh we've already done the wizard
ah you missed it my friend we've already
done the wizard
i think it's on bitchu we've already did
that movie
the reality is i have a life and i don't
watch other people play video games oh
oh hey hey don't get don't get sassy
miami was getting sassy
yeah but you watch me would you watch
you don't watch other people play video
games
but you watch me play cowboys dancing in
the outpost
which look i appreciate that is a much
better use of your time
oh i'm playing this yeah this is me i'm
doing this but i'll pretend
this is me i'm doing it
yeah watch this i'll just lie what if i
just
what if i just take other people's speed
runs and pretend it's me and claim the
world of record
angrily they're gonna get so mad and i
just claim
and i just claim that i'm the one doing
it right
and then people get really mad and i
know this is my world record you're
lying
i did this yeah we have similar play
styles but clearly i beat you by a
second
[ __ ] loser i don't know what to tell
you but i beat you
doing it right now right now
going for the speed run here we go
all right this part's difficult this
part's difficult coming up here i'm
glitching right now on purpose
i'm doing this glitch on purpose so i
can get through it
see
huh
yes yes i did it i guess
yes i did it yes i
did it i beat mario [ __ ] five
minutes yes yes
speed run whoa
speed run king baby
i did it thanks guys
please let me know any other games you
want me to speed run and i will speed
run them because i'm
very good i'm very good at speed running
give me another game the speed run i'll
do it right now
somebody yeah call the people that don't
call guinness workbook of world records
let them know that i did it
super awesome
i'm the speedrun king
whoa i
am offended yeah i know um
fallout 3 would take too long
so uh again guys i just want to thank
everybody for following me through my
entire speed run career
it um it means it means a lot to me
that you guys have been you know as you
know day wave has always been a speed
run channel
and um really happy that i was able to
to do this um the
the next game that i will be
uh that i will be speed running for you
today
um will be let's see
let's see let's see i'm gonna i'm so
good at this i can just pick any game
any game
and beat it right now it doesn't matter
and i get
and i'll get the world record
i'll get the world record
here's a good example i'm going to show
you look check this out
you guys are gonna love this all right
any mario 64 fans any mario 64 fans in
the audience
guess what i'm about to do a mario 64
speedrun i'm going for my world record
of 5 minutes and 34 seconds
this is gonna be really cool